We've learned a bit about affordances,
semantics and how assistive technologies
use the accessibility tree to create
an alternative user experience.
We also took a look at how
we can write expressive HTML
which makes this process as
straightforward as possible.
>> Right.
Writing semantic HTML gives it a lot
of accessibility out of the box.
Information such as form fields,
links and
a lot of complex behavior
is given to you for free.
I'd like to talk about a different
aspect of accessibility though.
And that is how does a screen
reader user actually finds and
then reads the information in the page.
>> Right yeah,
we haven't talked about how you actually
get around a page using a screen reader.
On something like the flight booking
site we looked at in the last lesson,
there's really not a lot
of content on the page.
So it's not a big deal to just
read the whole thing from the top.
But on something like
a newspaper front page or
an email application like Gmail, it's
not really going to be practical to read
through every single thing until
you find what you're looking for.
because you'd never get anything done.
>> So true.
Actually, you'd be surprised how many
people, when they start learning about
screen readers, assume that it's so
difficult and tedious to use.
And to compensate for their assumption,
they tend to do things like making every
element on the web page focusable.
So that a screen reader user has
an easier time getting to them.
I've been using screen reader
since my college years, and
today I'd like to show
you just how it works.